pour l enquête se poursuit à l'île
maurice après la marée noire provoquée
par un bateau japonais l'adjoint et le
capitaine du vraquier wac et chiots ont
été arrêtés hier ils ont été inculpés
pour atteinte à la sécurité de la
navigation d'autres membres de
l'équipage ont été entendus par la
police mme police mauricienne le
bâtiment s'était échoué avec 4000 tonnes
d'hydrocarbures à son bord une partie
s'est échappé a souillé les côtes
mauriciennes notamment des espaces
protégés
de son côté le japon a dépêché
aujourd'hui nouvelle équipe d'experts
sur place pour participer aux efforts de
dépollution entre comique en cas
autochtones et nous évaluerons
soigneusement l'environnement et des
dommages causés par la fuite de pétrole
sur le système écologique côtier en
particulier sur les coraux et les
mangroves en tant qu équipe de secours
d'urgence
nous aimerions apporter nos compétences
techniques pour aider à nettoyer la
forêt de mangrove couverte de pétrole